Try not to laugh challenge...
More like 'unfunny YouTubers react to copyrighted content'.
Y'all keep clicking on that
*silent giggle*
I could make an hour-long version of this and retire for good...
But what is this?
*Weird music with dog barks*
Dank edition...
Oh boy...
I love some dank memes man..
This is gonna be so tough
Because dank memes are just the hardest thing for me
I always giggle up really hard whenever a good dank meme shows up
Oh...
Let's watch!
Ainsley, are you with me?
*Emotional music*
Ainsley: As I am you...
Ainsley: You gave me life, you gave me this voice, this personality
Ainsley: I just want to be free.
Ainsley: Free from this cardboard prison, free from these paper shackles
Ainsley: Please Felix... Give me freedom, give me the sweet release of death
Ainsley: Watch out you don't spill the coffee, buddy.
For fuck's sake, I keep spilling the coffee on this shirt.
It's you versus me, bitch.
I'll make u laugh...
Ainsley: No, don't. I'm a virgin.
Even if I have to...
Alright, we're starting now...
*Music with 'bops'*
Dinosaur: Eeeeee!
*Music fades*
Next video.
'Best cat jump ever.'
*Thunk*
*Thud*
Ainsley.
Ainsley: Haha, cats are funny...
Gotchu!
I knew you would laugh!
*Clocks by Coldplay*
You...
Turtle: *Exhale*
Michael :you suck my cock!
Ha!
*Burst of laughter*
No, no..! That does not count!
I wasn't ready!
You can't just all the sudden do a...
'HA!'
HA!
What is going on here?
BREAKFAST!!!
Oh... I wanna laugh so bad at that...
Ohhh... It hurts here.
It's like holding in a sneeze.
Uugh...
BREAKFAST!!!
Mmmm...
Ainsley: You're a monster.
*Thunk, screaming*
I know where this meme's coming...
Here's... Jo-
Felix: *Unenthusiastically* John Cena.
*John Cena theme plays*
Ha ha ha haaa
[meow]
*Dramatic music*
Why are cats so funny? I don't fucking, like...
They shouldn't be, what the f...
[meow]
*Dramatic music*
This is a di-d-b-d...
OH!
Whoahoo!
Jesus!
That landing!
I could never do that!
'Dibidibidibidibe'
Alright... Well, it's not bad.
*Yelling over music*
No...
Cut that, we can't...
Mmhm...
Oh, they have Grotesco! (a Swedish comedy TV series)
[Swedish commentator]: Welcome to-
[Pewds]:It's Swedish! It's so funny...
[commentator]: -to the Paralympics, this is the first competition.
[Pewds]: I haven't seen this one though.
[commentator]: First up is Briton Andy McStraw
Whose greatest accomplishment is a silver from the 2005 World Championship in Nagoya.
[Pewds]: Okay, they're just introducing him...
[commentator]: He got the second place there, after the Russian...
[Pewds]: He got second after the Russian guy.
AHHHHHH
*Gunshot*
[commentator]: Oh yeah, right on target! And that shot can go a long way for McStraw...
Oh...
Swedish people...
*Laughs*
And people think my sense of humor is bad...
What the fuck...
Thank you, on that note we're gonna end this dank meme compe-
Did you like it? Did you laugh?
Ainsley: Haha haha
*Both laughing robotically*
*Dramatic music*
*Deep voice* The time has come.
*Deep voice* He suspects nothing.
*Deep voice* Soon...
*Deep voice* I will rise.
Leave a like if you enjoyed watching, I need more likes because... Uhm...
Subscribe to become a bro today, uhm...
Because Minecraft channels are still a thing and I'll see you bros in the next video. Stay awesome bros.
Bye!
*Outro music*